au creux de la vallée du haut doubs à la
frontière franco suisse
il faut se rendre au pied du col des
roches pour entamer un voyage au centre
de la terre
ici l'eau à creuser cette grotte
naturelle elle est vraiment typique des
milieu karstique de la région donc c'est
du calcaire dans lequel l'eau
s'engouffre lots à creuser ce calcaire
au fil des millénaires pour arriver à
cette structure très particulière le
biais donc la rivière qui traverse le
loch s'engouffre dedans c'est donc
l'endroit du lock on a le plus d'eau et
le plus d'énergie hydraulique boxer
l'endroit où c'est le plus commode
d'installer des moulins qui
fonctionneront bien à l'origine la
rivière formaient une chute d'une
dizaine de mètres
cette force hydraulique les hommes vont
l'utiliser dès le xviie siècle 3 meunier
installèrent les premiers moulins la
farine et est fabriqué à partir de grain
d'orge et d'avoine cultivés sur place
les céréales étaient jetés depuis la
trémie supérieur dont on voit ici
l'embouchure
elles vont glisser évidemment dans la
2ème trémie et à partir de là elles vont
passer entre les meules lapierre
servante a écrasé les céréales étaient
généralement du grès car le calcaire
locales n'étaient pas idéales
il est trop poreux il est trop fragile
aussi issus très rapidement et donc ça
fera des meules de très mauvaise qualité
les hommes firent preuve d'ingéniosité
pour installer trois grandes roues
motrices à la seule force de leurs bras
il dure a ménagé plusieurs cavités à 22
mètres de profondeur les roues étaient
construites par des spécialistes dans
leurs ateliers
ensuite elles étaient démontés le
menuisier
l'essai les parties de sa roue dans la
grotte pour qu'elle prenne l'humidité à
une fois que le gua était bien habitué à
l'humidité du lieu
le menuisier à les remonter sa roue par
7 degrés dans l'obscurité le rythme le
travail des hommes les roues entraîne
des meules à grains mais aussi une
scierie puis au 19e siècle la vallée est
drainée la rivière canalisée pour mettre
fin aux inondations le niveau de l'eau
disponible dans la grotte a baissé la
roue tourne et la fée électricité
condamne définitivement les moulins
souterrains
à l'aube du xxème siècle le site devient
un abattoir frontière où les bêtes
importés de france se sont contrôlées
les moulins sont laissés à l'abandon et
plus que ça même puisque l'abattoir aura
la très mauvaise idée d'utiliser la
grotte comme un dépotoir en fait pour
toutes les parties
carnet en consommables donc pendant des
dizaines d'années on avait très peu de
conscience écologique à l'époque on va
déverser ses déchets carnés dans la
grotte des bénévoles vont nettoyer ce
patrimoine exceptionnel qui deviendra en
1987 amusé ce qu'on voulait à l'origine
c'est rendre le lieu plus accueillant
pour les visiteurs parce que quand on
arrivait ici qu'est ce qu'on voyait en
voyant une espèce de chantier on a
décidé effectivement de réaménager la
place en question pour ça bien sûr qu'il
a fallu chercher de l'argent et de la
fondation des moulins du col qui s'est
chargé de cette opération
pour arriver à ce projet
depuis l'ère industrielle l'homme
cherche à maîtriser l'eau ils oublient
qu'à une autre époque c'est l'eau qui
dictait la vie et l'activité des hommes